a survivor  fire called the war Judgment Day the  images feel more real in 3d  there's a lucidity to it you really feel  like you're there  we're talking about 25 years later a lot  of fans of the movie weren't even born  one was made who sent you  you did it down so for a lot of people  it'll just be the thrill of seeing in a  movie theater  come with me if you want to live on top  of that of course you've got the fact  that it's in 3d  we're working with the best 3d  conversion house in the world which is  stereo D hasta LaVista baby to progress  very quickly - very good result just  can't go around killing people why I'm a  terminator  [Music]  I've been looking at the film as we're  completing the 3d it looks pretty  spectacular I'll be back  you  you